global warming is caused by cow farts
it's not
by their farts but it's by belching a
few degrees different
is not a big deal and the way i always
like to think about too is like
your body's temperature if your
temperature is three or four degrees
warmer then
you're seriously sick it's too late to
do anything about it unless you're elon
musk and gonna
head off towards mars we're all stuck
here so we should try to figure out how
we can make it the best planet we can
i'm dt singh i'm an assistant professor
in the school of the environment at
washington state university
i've been studying climate change for
about 11 years and
i study extreme weather events and how
human activities are
influencing them my name is benjamin
cook and i'm a climate scientist at the
nasa goddard institute for space studies
i've been working there for about 14
years now and i study how
droughts are changing with global
warming and climate change and today
we'll be debunking myths about global
warming
myths from pop culture oh boy i'm glad
you got this one deep d
the sun is causing global warming
changes in the amount of energy we get
from the sun do
affect our climate but over the last 150
years we know that because the amount of
energy we're getting from the sun has
not changed significantly over this
period
satellites have been recording the
amount of solar radiation that our
planet receives
i think ben has a graph that shows that
what we're looking at here on the yellow
is the amount of energy that's
coming from the sun and red is global
temperatures it's pretty clear that the
amount of energy we're getting from the
sun
has been more or less flat for the last
several decades even as temperatures
continue to go up and up scientists
don't agree on what causes climate
change
100 of the climate scientists on this
skype call agree
if you review the published literature
in reputable journals by reputable
scientists
all those papers agree that climate
change is caused by human activities
there's really no other explanation that
fits the data
we've looked at the sun we've looked at
just natural variations in
circulation in the ocean and the
atmosphere we've looked at volcanoes
we've looked at
changes in ecosystems and at the end of
the day the only thing
that can adequately explain the degree
of warming that we've seen over the last
150 years
is human greenhouse gas emissions
primarily through the burning of fossil
fuels
there's a real clear incentive for
people to find some other explanation
nobody can come up with even a plausible
alternative hypothesis
global warming is caused by cow farts
it's not by their farts but it's by
belching agriculture is a pretty
substantial contributor to greenhouse
gas emissions
close to 25 it's not the whole 25 but
it's a good chunk
it's important to know too that even the
cow burps that are producing this
methane is not natural it's all part of
a
kind of human agricultural system so
blaming it all on
cows doesn't take people off the hook
plants and animals will adapt
so we know that in the past plants and
animals have adapted to climate change
but there's a few
fundamental different things now that
are very likely to make it
quite difficult in addition it's not
just
climate change that's threatening plants
and animals it's habitat fragmentation
it's an environment pollution it's a
variety of other environmental stressors
and so once you kind of
put climate change on top of pollution
on top of habitat loss then it becomes
much much more difficult
and just to add to that i think the
extinction rate of species
is much higher than the natural
extinction rate
and it's partly driven by the processes
that ben just mentioned
this from social media global warming is
natural so we know in the past that
climate can change really dramatically
from
natural causes the climate during the
time of the dinosaurs is very different
from the climate during the time of the
last ice age but the changes that we're
seeing right now
for the most part are not natural the
warming that we're seeing is very likely
the
fastest warming we've seen any time in
the last several thousand years
it coincides directly with the
industrial revolution and the burning of
fossil fuels and widespread
deforestation
you can look at almost any natural cause
and
none of them are sufficient to explain
the warming that we've seen in recent
decades
carbon dioxide is the problem so co2
isn't the problem
it's the increase in the concentration
of co2 in the atmosphere
that is resulting in the rapid warming
we're seeing over the last century
which is the problem so carbon dioxide
is one of these
gases that we call greenhouse gases
because they're responsible for the
greenhouse effect which
basically helps trap energy on earth and
make things much much warmer than it
otherwise would have been it's not a big
stretch then to observe that if we start
increasing co2 concentrations we're
going to trap more energy
and we're gonna warm up before the
industrial revolution
co2 levels were close to like 280 parts
per million and now we're
at close to 418 parts per million so
that's a pretty
large change in the concentration the
fact is that pretty much
any time the world was warmer
co2 levels in the atmosphere were higher
and any time the world was cooler
the co2 concentrations were lower a few
degrees difference is not a big deal the
way i always like to think about too is
like
your body's temperature we're all
supposed to be about 98.6 degrees
fahrenheit
even one degree or two degrees of
warming is considered a low grade fever
and if your temperature is three or four
degrees warmer then
you're seriously sick so just to give
you a sense the earth has warmed by
about one degree
over the last century that one degree is
an average
temperature around our planet that means
some parts of our planet are warming
faster
than others i come from india we have a
lot of people that live
below poverty in the country and most of
those people
for example don't have an air
conditioner to deal with extreme heat
events
so it depends on who we're talking about
when we say it's not a big deal
because there are some people around the
planet that have the capacity to adapt
or cope
with these kind of extreme events and
with the warming that we've experienced
and then there are
billions of people that do not have the
capacity to cope
with even small changes myths that
we climate scientists hear the most
global warming will destroy the planet
by 2030.
just like there's kind of climate
deniers who don't know what they're
talking about there's climate doomists
who also don't know what they're talking
about
this whole idea of the planet being
destroyed by
2030 comes out of discussion about how
much time do we have to keep global
warming under two degrees
and so it's very likely that we need to
kind of get emissions under control by
2030 to keep it under two degrees
it doesn't mean that the world is going
to explode or we're all going to be
consigned to a
fiery mad max kind of hellscape
it just means that it'll be warmer than
we maybe wanted it to be
when they say it's going to destroy the
planet well the planet's not going to
blow up but it does mean that the way of
life
and the livelihoods and the things
people depend on are going to be
affected there are already people who
have been displaced because of sea level
rise people that are experiencing
life-threatening heat conditions
the impacts of climate change are not
going to be equally felt these kind of
blanket statements are very very
dismissive and i think they can take
attention
away from the people who are likely to
be most vulnerable to climate change
it's not really helpful to put a date on
it i think we just need to know that
delaying action on climate change is
going to just cost more to society
global warming is china's fault so to
address that myth i think there's one
important fact we need to understand
when co2 is emitted
it can stay in the atmosphere for
hundreds if not thousands of years the
co2 concentrations we're seeing today
are a consequence of emissions that have
happened
over a much longer period over the last
century and
most of those emissions are associated
with the industrial revolution
and development of countries like the us
and
industrialized nations in europe if we
look at emissions
this year specifically sure the
emissions from
china are close to what the emissions
from the us are
but those emissions are being used to
produce products and goods that are
being used in other parts of the world
so i don't think it's fair to say that
china is responsible when we're
all benefiting from the products that
are produced there
i think even today it's worth thinking
not just about
how much is a country emitting but how
much are they emitting per person and
i have another visual aid here you can
pretty clearly see
the highest intensity emitters are
places like australia
the us canada russia saudi arabia china
isn't even in the top ten
it's also a complicated problem because
the well-being of people is tied
to their consumption of energy so as
long as we're doing that
in a sustainable cleaner way i think we
all have to benefit from it
renewable energy is too expensive to be
realistic
renewable energy is getting cheaper
all the time even faster than we
expected
and there's a lot of places where it
actually can out compete some fossil
fuel sources for example i believe
wind and solar is more
cost effective than coal in pretty much
the entire
united states the cost of producing
solar panels
today is a fraction of what it was just
a decade ago
i keep going back to india because
that's another region i'm very familiar
with there are a lot of villages there
that have been provided energy
because they're using solar and wind
which would not have been possible if we
were still depending
upon co2 no there's still challenges
we're not going to kind of
be able to switch everything over
overnight but
it's like any other technology it's
getting cheaper
over time it's getting more efficient
and the more we kind of invest in it
then the faster we'll get to the point
that we'll be able to use it for
most of our needs extreme weather isn't
caused by global warming
so the right question to ask is not
whether an extreme event would have been
possible
without warming but it's to ask how
the event itself was affected by warming
for example
a tropical storm or a tropical cyclone
might
result in heavier precipitation because
a warmer atmosphere holds more moisture
and so there's more moisture more fuel
in the storm which results in
heavier precipitation and likely more
flooding i think a good analogy is a
professional athlete on steroids
athletes need to have some kind of
innate fitness and ability
but if you go on steroids you're a bit
more likely to hit a home run so co2 is
kind of like the steroids of the climate
system and it's just intensifying
everything that's already there the
temperature record is unreliable
what do you have to say about that then
the record we have of warming for the
last 150 years is constructed from
basically thousands of thermometer
records from around the world
climate scientists often get accused of
modifying the temperature record to make
it look like it's warming more than it
actually is
at least half a dozen groups around the
world we're all independently
putting together these records and
estimating the global temperature
changes that we've seen over the last
two centuries and they're all basically
getting the same answer all this data is
publicly available
anybody can go and get this data and
come up with their own calculation
and the fact is that nobody has shown
one that is credibly different it's too
late to do anything about it
it's easy for us to say well it's too
late to anything about it let's throw
our hands up and not do anything about
it
but there is a lot we can do about it
both individually as well as
at the international level it doesn't
have to be a major change but
reducing our consumption of certain
meat products that are extremely energy
intensive is one way in which we can
affect
greenhouse emissions the decisions we
make today we are going to have to deal
with our children are going to
live with i will never say that people
should not recycle
or reduce their car use or eat less meat
but at the end of the day
the big levers is going to be government
because the government can set policies
that can incentivize actions it's also a
weird time to say that it's too late to
do anything about it because
we're at a point in time when we have so
much information
there are people working on technologies
to address climate change and to make
our environment cleaner and better
so this is not a time for us to put our
hands up it's our time to take action
climate change itself is not pass fail
keeping warming to three degrees is
better than four degrees
keeping warming to two and a half
degrees is better than three degrees
keeping warming to two degrees is better
than all those things we're all stuck
here so we should try to figure out how
we can make it the best planet we can
climate change
are a global solution and people to
actually
kind of work together